well it's Christmas and for me certainly
that means revisiting Charles Dickens
Christmas Carol and the man in poverty
better than anybody else's the actor
Simon Callow currently got one-man show
on at the arts theater playing all the
parts including including Scrooge I mean
obviously 2016 has been an extraordinary
you stick to the literature but what are
the echoes you're picking up as you're
performing yet well I mean I think that
we we find ourselves having a lot in
common with Victorian England in sense
that there's a huge disparity in income
between people and a general sense of a
political drift which Dickens was very
familiar with Dickens was a far from
committed Democrat he thought that
democracy had basically failed already
in 1843 and so his his book is about
direct action it's about really doing
something about it about charity direct
personal charity personal involvement
and I think that's that certainly rings
a bell have you've been all his
arguments about you know what Queen
Victoria or Napoleon would have been I
mean would Dickens have been a brexit
here or Ramona it that's a tricky one
actually because he because resented and
hated what he thought it was Catholic
Europe so he hated Italy basically and
in France but but was very keen on
Switzerland he thought well it is no but
the interesting thing is that he was a
big referendum man Dickens was a
believer in plebiscites he thought the
Swiss system was the ideal one single
issue referendum because as I say he had
so little faith in democracy so I don't
know what he would have felt about any
notion of the United States of Europe
and when he wrote Christmas Carol me he
was a commercial writer and he wanted to
make money obviously but was he trying
to change anything was he really trying
to sort of wake people up Oh desperately
with that particular book yes because
he'd like everybody else he'd read the
parliamentary report on the employment
of children in mines and it had totally
devastated Victorian Britain because
that it was the price of their huge
expansion and world Dominion which was
only beginning then which would go on to
be much greater but so suddenly people
saw that these children
desperate ravaged feral little children
were being that were the you know the
fuel of all of that and so Diggins
determined to write as he said a hammer
blow against it and oddly enough he
thought first of all he'd write a speech
and then the Christmas carol came up
which is so much more than just that but
at the heart of it which is the bit that
most people forget is that when the
spirit of Christmas present takes his
leave of screwed she opens the folds of
his garment and there are these terrible
little as Dickens has migas scowling
wolfish children once called want and
the others called ignorance and the
spirit says this they wear them both but
particularly boy they wear the boy
because he has that written on his brow
who do mankind and the character of
Scrooge and the dead Molly as well yeah
they really did sort of set the tone of
how people regard plutocrats bankers
finances yeah from then on they they're
baddies hahaha I think they were great
baddies before actually but but he
absolutely defined who he is a miser
Scrooge above all and the great thing
about the story is that it is he of all
people is given a second chance he's
given a chance to get it right and
that's I think what makes it so very
moving he returns to society as a useful
member of society and spreads his money
around and you know a lot of sponsorship
of the Arts some of it controversial do
you think they've learnt the lesson that
they do need to put something back or is
Goldman Sachs and the rest of it vampire
squids is that what bridge works today I
feel he does yes or did or would have
done but as for the as for the arts well
of course I mean Dickens believed so
passionately that art would heal the
book the community bring it back
together again he felt that his whole
society was diffracted and he wanted to
bring it together was his whole life's
work and that also we can't feel other
than identification with a lot of people
also saying that you know books call
this now that Dickens invented Christmas
yeah did he I think there's a sense in
which he did he sort of put it on the
map in a new way I think he gave it
meaning
a different kind of meaning he said
basically as his character Fred
Scrooge's nephew says that miss
Christmas is the one time of the year
when people open their closed up hearts
freely and look on those below them as
fellow passengers to the grave and I
think Dickens his big point was if you
can do it at Christmas why can't you do
it or via wrong because the Victorians
are very big on charity at Christmas but
it was a once-a-year thing and some of
the trappings as well the you know the
slap up meals and all that yes except
that remember the great meal in it is
the is the cratchits which is a
miserable little goose and a tiny little
pudding but what he says is that's they
they they make that into a glorious
feast their imagination does that for
them but but the massive banquets
actually they come from a slightly
earlier generation that's from
Washington Irving and all of that so
Dickens is always about the ordinary
people and the or the sanctifying
ordinary life now you are portraying the
part but you know they've been so many
versions of every Christmas couple I
have to be I rather like a muppet what
are your favorite well I I have to go
back to Alastair sim you know he
conveyed Scrooge as well as anybody it's
a rather wonderful film with some
wonderful and vintage actors but
advantage if I may say so of the one-man
version is that I can reproduce the
fluidity of the book because I can
summon up the fezziwig's ball in a few
phrases and then discard it and move
right on to the next thing whereas with
a film or in a play you have to sort of
because I physically is it all alright
you're gonna give us a Christmas tree
and a Christmas carol over to you
alright this is where the charity
gentlemen come to try to get some money
out of screws I say Scrooge and Marley's
I believe do I have the pleasure of
addressing mr. Scrooge or mr. Marley mr.
Marley has been dead these seven years
he died seven years ago this very night
well no doubt his surviving partner
represents his liberality a few of us
mr. Scrooge trying to get together a
fund to buy the poor and the destitute
who suffer so terribly at this time of
year food and drink and some means of
warmth thousands hundreds of thousands
lack to these bare
chasity to say nothing of ordinary human
comforts are there no prisons oh yes
plenty of prison sir and the Union
workhouses are they still in operation
yes very busy thank God I thought from
what you said that something that
occurred to stop them in their useful
work but businessman mr. Scrooge they
successfully offer Christian comfort of
mind and body what may I put you down
for nothing but you wish to remain
anonymous I wish to be left alone I
don't make merry myself at Christmas and
I can't afford to make idle people merry
I support the prisons and the work
houses and if people need them then they
must go there but many can't go there
mr. Scrooge and many would rather die if
they'd rather die they'd better do it
and decrease the surplus population
good afternoon that's the Scrooge Ian
view but it it has a happy ending we
should run oh well the happy ending is
that Scrooge as I say is is is redeemed
and goes back to life and spreads it
around a bit I what is it what does he
say at the end god bless us everyone
that's Tiny Tim observed Sankara thank
you very much indeed thank you